[Music]
similarly with the universality of the
essence that is with the determination
of the content by pure consciousness
conscience when it proceeds to action
enters into relation with the many
aspects of the case the case breaks up
into its various separate parts and so
too does the relation of pure
consciousness to it with the result that
the manifold nature of the case becomes
a multiplicity of duties conscience
knows that it has to choose between them
and to make a decision for none of them
in its specific character or in its
content is absolute only pure Duty is
that but this abstraction of pure Duty
has attained in its reality the
significance of the self conscious I the
self certain spirit rest qua conscience
within itself and it's real universality
or its duty lies in its pure conviction
of duty this pure conviction is as such
empty as pure Duty is pure in the sense
that there's nothing in it no specific
content that is a duty but action is
called for something must be determined
by the individual and the self certain
spirit in which the in itself has
attained the significance of the self
conscious I knows that it has this
determination and content in the
immediate certainty of itself this as a
determination and content is the natural
consciousness that is impulses and
inclinations conscience does not
recognize the absoluteness of any
content for it is the absolute
negativity of everything determinate it
determines from its own self but the
sphere of the self into which falls the
determinant is such as the so called
sense nature to have a content taken
from the immediate certainty of itself
means that it has nothing to draw on but
sense nature everything that in previous
forms of experience presented itself as
good or bad as law and right is
something other than the immediate
certainty of self it is a universal
which is now a being for another or
looked at from
another aspect it is an object which
while mediating consciousness with
itself comes between consciousness and
its own truth so that instead of the
object being the immediacy of
consciousness it rather cuts
consciousness off from itself for
conscience however self certainty is the
pure immediate truth and this truth is
thus its immediate certainty itself
conceived as content that is this truth
is in general the Caprice of the
individual and the contingency of his
unconscious natural being his sense
nature
there is quite a bit going on here in
paragraph 643 we're looking at how this
this form of consciousness that Hegel
calls conscience is developing itself
and you notice that one of the things
running throughout this entire section
this last part of morality before we
start getting into some of the really
cool shapes like you know the beautiful
soul and you know evil and its
forgiveness and all of that sort of
stuff is the the problematic of
conscience itself we've seen this play
itself out at several points in the
dialectic earlier on in the
phenomenology where you have something
that is you might say putting itself
forward as a universal and in the face
of other universals in this case it's
the individual consciousness that has a
conscience who is engaging in what it
believes to be moral action and it's
judging that moral action by conscience
in the face of other things and so Hegel
wants to say here as he's going to do by
the end of it you know for conscience
self certainty is the pure immediate
truth and this truth is its immediate
certainty of self conceived as content
now anytime that we're seeing immediacy
self certainty anything like that
we should already be you might say
dialectically on our guard you know that
Hegel is going to show that there's more
involved there and that this truth that
we're seeing of self certainty is not
really going to be self certain there's
going to be a problem once we start
untangling it and there's there's quite
a complex problematic already here
in this section so let's dive in he says
with the universality of the essence the
determination of the content the in halt
by pure consciousness it goes similarly
as it does for what he's just talked
about so we might back up a little bit
into the previous paragraph where he
talks about this acquaintance with and
weighing all the circumstances existing
only as a moment something which is only
for others and it's incomplete
so the universality of the essence now
is the other side of that that he's
looking at that is also going to be to
some degree incomplete what does that
mean to say that it that it's incomplete
it means that it's as Hegel in his
terminology it's a moment among a whole
bunch of connected moments it's not the
entire show it's not the one thing that
determines and drives everything else
instead they're mutually determining and
you know if you think about it is a
little bit of a digression if you think
about how it actually works out for us
in the decisions that we make where we
do in fact consult something like what
we're calling conscience here Hegel
doesn't mean conscience by the way as
that little still voice in the back of
the head or the angel sitting on your
shoulder as opposed to the devil or
anything quite so so formulaic or
imaginary he means that there's a sort
of sifting out on the part of the
individual who actually wants to fulfill
their their duties they're pricked a--
in german right there their obligations
and doesn't quite have them all sorted
out and what they are and has to rely on
something that isn't going to be pure
intuition or pure feeling but can argue
for itself in some ways maybe in ways
that not everybody else can necessarily
buy into unless they have certain
experiences or certain insights but but
certainly to some some degree so let's
let's go
with us now that was just sort of a
teaser to get into it and let's talk
about what's actually happening in this
section so he says conscience when it
proceeds to action enters into relation
with the many aspects of the case and
this is not a unfamiliar schema right so
we have conscience as a particular
Gestalt a particular shape of
consciousness here in the morality
section it's engaging in action or
comportment or behavior honden right and
then what is action always applied to
particulars you don't act in a purely
general way because if you do you never
actually act you have to act on
particulars and so those particulars
come they comprise what we call here the
case you know the BA in German the
situation would be another way of
translating it which makes it sound a
little bit more existentialist you know
when we talk about you know choosing in
the situation or something like that but
that's that's really the way it works
I don't decide what I'm going to do
about my children and whether to you
know have them here over fall break
despite the fact that it will you know
require me to engage in a lot of driving
and you know I have to reorganize my
schedule but it's good for them to be up
here and spend some time engaging in
things together and bonding and all of
that sort of I that's a specific case
right I could say more generally well
what about children and spending time
with their parents when they live at a
distance now it's a bit more Universal
it's a bit more general right and we
could we could generalize it up the line
children spending time with parents and
now we've lost some of the specificity
of it right the taking out the at a
distance we've turned it into something
that's rather generic and purports to be
universal but is lacking in what Hegel
here is calling content right so a
specific case is where we actually do
our
acting I drive down and pick up those
kids and bring them back here and we
have particular conversations and
particular interactions even for perhaps
particular disagreements and meltdowns
and fights that then we have to work
through in particular ways so that they
can learn the right lesson or not learn
the right lessons right
all of those are what we call the
multiple aspects of the case here's
where it starts to become really
interesting and again not something
radically new that Hegel is bringing up
here he's discussed this a number of
times
but the case breaks up into its various
separate parts those separate parts are
part of the totality that is the case
and skipping ahead a little bit into the
next paragraph I just want to you know
you might say Telegraph or foreshadow a
bit each of those parts can be
emphasized on its own as being what's
really essential to the case and very
often when we get into conflicts with
each other about what actually happened
it's because people are seizing upon
different aspects and saying that's
what's really essential in somebody over
here saying no no you've got it wrong
this is what is really essential to the
case so you know that's something good
to keep in mind as we move forward
here's what what Hegel has to say says
the case breaks up into its separate
parts and so too does the relation of
pure consciousness to it why because it
is breaking the the manifold nature of
the case into a multiplicity of duties
again when we get to specific cases
there are a whole set of duties that are
involved in it so you know if I take for
example driving down to get my my kids
for their fall break and you know
hanging out with them over the course of
a weekend
getting them back right there's several
different duties involved there some of
them are things that would be the case
for any time that the kids are here like
feeding them and you know actually
interacting with them as a parent
obviously if they if they come up here
and I say okay you know you're on your
own there's there's your place to sleep
enjoy yourself and then I'm like see you
later I got to go to London for a
conference or something like that
I'm not fulfilling a duty and it's it's
that's a particular duty I should be
there I should be engaged with them I
should you know act as a parent driving
down to pick them up if I if I'm there
on time I'm fulfilling my duty maybe
traffic is bad you know and it takes me
an extra hour to get there well I didn't
fulfill my duty to be there at that time
there's a multiplicity of different
duties and you know interestingly if we
fulfill some or don't fulfill some all
the way that may give rise to yet other
duties you get into a big fight well now
you have a duty to fix that fight right
you have a duty to figure out what went
wrong and put things back as we stay on
the proverbial rails and reconcile and
all of those sorts of things so any
concrete action that we're engaging in
within a real-life situation is going to
not only have a multiplicity of aspects
it's going to have a multiplicity of
duties a you know manifold if you like
or you know folding out into a number of
different things
sometimes we're taken by surprise aren't
we we're like holy crap I had no idea
that this job entailed quite so much you
know I'll give you another great example
every time that I take on a class with a
new institution you know they say hey we
want you to teach ethics for us or you
know teach some business ethics or teach
some intro to philosophy and I'm like
well okay how much does it pay and how
many students am I going to have and
what's your course management system and
when do you want it done by and and
we're like okay this is this all
works out then I sign a contract or you
know sometimes agree to a contract in
the online setting and then we get down
to the nitty-gritty right it turns out
that you can't upload things the way
that you'd like to so the videos have to
be reprocessed and uploaded in this way
and you know the grading system doesn't
work the way it's supposed to be and
then all these extra emails come out
from administrators saying we want this
from you we want this from you we want
this from you and then you get the
students with the accommodations you
know where some of them are like I have
to have this this accommodation made for
me and you've got now a whole bunch of
extra duties that you didn't really
realize that you were getting in for as
a matter of fact most things in life are
like that aren't they so going back to
the Hegel once again Hegel tells us that
conscience here's why there's a issue
here conscience knows that it has to
choose between these duties and to make
a decision so it has to engage in Velen
you know selection you know or you might
say valuation of one thing against
another prioritization and a decision
and Schiedam you know splitting them
apart literally and saying this is what
we're going to do this takes lower
priority so Hegel then says why none of
them in its specific character and its
content is absolute only pure Duty is
absolute so anytime that we have decided
that one specific thing in the case is
going to be treated as if it's absolute
as if it's the most important that's on
us we bear responsibility for it that's
not just something that comes down from
on high and you know the voice of the
lord says in all these manifold aspects
of the case this is the one that matters
the most right make sure that you keep
the you know the table clean or
something like that and people sometimes
go very wrong with these don't
in selecting the wrong things you know
for example I'm as a professor I might
be really really interested in my duty
of making sure that all of the students
get to study Aristotle
well that's that's good in the class but
that's not the only thing the class is
about and if I prioritize that wrongly
as the pure or absolute duty I might be
leaving out all sorts of other things as
well so conscience that it is
responsible for this conscience has to
choose between these now here's where we
get to another conflict he says this
abstraction of pure duty has attained in
its reality the significance of the self
conscious eye the eye of conscience
right the self certain spirit rests as
conscience in itself and it's real
universality or its duty lies in its
pure conviction you Birdseye going in in
German of duty
it tells itself a story that it has this
this you know duty that is the most
important that is the pure duty but it's
really you know it's deciding this for
itself now a little bit of a pause here
if this starts to sound rather
existentialist it's not because you're
reading existentialism back into Hegel
it's because as the French you know
readers of Hegel certainly recognize
there are a lot of existentialist
moments within Hegel when you get down
into the nitty-gritty I know that people
think you know because they do this
big-picture philosophy that you know
Hegel was all about the universal and
the existentialism is about the
individual Hegel is about both so coming
back to it to this what does he say pure
conviction is as such as empty as pure
Duty it's pure in the sense that there
is nothing in it no specific content
that is a duty that doesn't help you
very much all right so so this feeling
of you know i'm i've got this pure duty
I'm pure conviction that only lasts for
a while and then you start saying well
what is it I actually have to do and
then now we're back into the concrete
actual action you know we could say
vehicle Iike Honda Land if we wanted to
action that is aimed at real things at
realities vehicle chiton so he goes on
and says action is called for something
must be determined by the individual the
self certain spirit in which the in
itself has attained the significance of
the self conscious I knows that it has
this determination and content in the
immediate certainty of its self
immediate certainty of itself what does
this immediate certainty look like here
is where you know we've got the pure
conviction of duty right up on top a
universal but empty where do we get our
our self certainty from as individuals
as tangible living human beings with
bodies well Hegel says that this is a
determination stimming Heights right and
content in halt is the natural
consciousness and what is natural
natural not just in the sense of oh well
that's human nature people act like
jerks or something like that no what
what is it to be natural in this this
respect this is a very sort of conscient
where it's our impulses and inclinations
or if you like drives kleebach alright
the things that are driving us towards
something our sex drive for example our
drive to eat our drive to you know fit
ourselves into a social hierarchy all of
these things are at Lieber right if you
want to get Freudian with it the
pleasure principle is one of those
drives right and then the the Thanatos
thing whatever that happens to be for it
kind of goes back and forth about that
is a drive
inclinations noggin you know literally
being inclined towards one thing or
another you know for example one of my
inclinations is to sleep in in the
morning if I had my my opportunities I
would you know schedule my workday so it
began around ten o'clock and sleep in
until eight or nine then get up and have
a leisurely breakfast and then you know
start getting on with the day and you
know maybe do there's other inclinations
that I have as well as a physical being
I like exercise but not too much of it
right and then after exercise they like
to lay around and you know eat some
stuff to replenish whatever it is that
I've lost and have some nice you know
popsicles you know to replenish you know
it's a cool down a bit or whatever it's
gonna be all right
we have these we have these drives and
inclinations every single one of us and
they're different some of them from each
other these give us as he says
determination and content conscience he
says does not recognize the absoluteness
of any content why because conscience is
negativity it determines from its own
self but the sphere of the self into
which falls the determinant is is the so
called sense nature to have a Content
taken from the immediate certainty of
itself means it has nothing to draw on
but since nature which is only a part of
who we are as human being so what is
Hegel talking about here as sense nature
another expression that you see is
sensibility or sensuousness it's you
know essentially what we actually have
it I have to be a little bit careful
here it's not just what we have in
common with the other non rational
animals because even human sense nature
is a bit different be precisely because
we're not just animals that rationality
part even if the rationality is not
being used is a little bit different
this is why Aristotle you know in
politics book one says that the
corruption of the best is actually the
worst
but this is this is part of where we get
our content from so it could be
expressed you know for example in action
maybe my natural conscious impulses the
Tabor there with respect to my children
are sort of you know fundamental
affection for those who are like me
those who I've spent time with those who
in certain ways have their origin in me
right that that could be part of what's
going on here so that I see is on
certain aspects of the case but that's
not enough to really be moral is it so
he goes on and he says everything that
in previous forms of experience
presented itself is good and bad law
right is something other than the
immediate certainty of self something
coming in from the outside something
imposing demands on us you know which
would include not just the moral law but
also the laws of the land we view those
as extrinsic to our own desires
maybe somebody passes laws that conform
to our desires our or we get in charge
right but he goes on and he says it's a
universal which is now at being for
another or looked at from another aspect
it's an object which while mediating
consciousness with itself comes between
consciousness and its own truth so that
instead of the object being the
immediacy of consciousness
it cuts consciousness off from itself
and then here we come back to the the
point that we began for consciousness
for conscience self certainly is the
pure immediate truth this truth is its
immediate certainty of self conceived as
content this truth and here's a thing we
left out is in general the Caprice the
Wilk ur right the arbitrariness of the
individual and the contingency of his
unconscious natural being that is the
sense nature so this does towards the
end come to sound like Hegel's not not
being a conscience retracing some of the
steps that Kant would trace but you know
other other thinkers as well
we have to be on guard against a kind of
particularism that comes out of our own
sense nature our own individuality our
own bodily nature and be careful that
we're not simply substituting our own
desires for actual duty and we're placed
in kind of a tricky spot right because
in order to ratify it as Duty conscience
has to be able to say yes to it if it's
something that's merely coming in from
the outside then conscience has a harder
time recognizing it as something that
really does have a you could say have a
moral right to impose itself as morality
upon us right so morality for Hegel has
to come from within from conscience and
it has to be something that we can be
certain of and it has to apply to
real-life situations
so we're in kind of a bind at the end of
this paragraph are we not
you